après les mystères de paris
les mystères de jean marais c'est chez
lui à marnes-la-coquette que nous avons
tenté de les déchiffrer
jean marc est cela fait pas mal d'années
que vous êtes notre jeune premier à la
mode
ah non je vous interromps tout de suite
pourquoi bonne idée rivière je ne suis
pas j'ai le premier je me suis jamais
considéré comme un jeune premier et je
ne considère toujours pas corrigé en
l'occurrence et l'opinion des autres qui
compte ici me demande ce qui vous engage
et ils pensent ces autres que vous
pouvez lutter avec des garçons qui ont
quelquefois la moitié de votre âge alors
une question se pose aussitôt comment
comment faites-vous m'a fait mon coin je
serai comme vous l'avez je ne cherche
pas à lutter du tout ça ne m'intéresse
pas de lutter je trouve que que une un
acteur qui arrive nouveaux ne seront pas
la place d'un acteur anciens pour rester
dans la forme à laquelle vous trouvez
est-ce que vous suivez un régime est ce
que vous faites quelque chose de
particulier non je ne je crois que si
vous voulez absolument un secret c'est
ça le secret c'est de ne rien faire
parce que je pense que le sport doit
fatigué beaucoup et doit vous faire
vieillir voilages mais de toute façon je
trouve que que je parais l'âge que j'ai
j'ai 48 ans et les gens qui font vieux
quoi de la guerre il ya tellement de
gens qui montent sur le roi sur la rage
que lorsque les gens disent de 48 en
général annonce 55 alors on se dit
évidemment celui qui dit son vrai âge a
l'air plus jeune c'est tout mais vous
n'avez pas vous n'avez pas de règle que
huit spéciales n'auront pas de culture
physique j'ai mal régime j'ai horreur de
ça même même vous voyez que
que je dois me baigner ici mais je ne le
fais pas un sport c'est à dire je prends
un bain de soleil quand j'ai trop chaud
je mets dans l'eau vaut pour me
rafraîchir mais je le fais pas tant que
sportif a pas dessus du marché tout ça
est parfaitement injuste aux sommes
investies pas fait de millionnaire
santécois nommé jeune con si je me
traite un peu comme un animal
oui je vis à mes instincts je mange
kosumi envie je crois quand je n'ai
envie et voilà il se trouve que j'ai des
instincts qui sont assez sérieux
vous avez toujours été comme ça ou ça
vous jouer un jour non non non j'ai
toujours été comme ça depuis je suis
très jeune mais est ce que ça vous êtes
arrivé justement vous parlez des animaux
en observant les animaux notamment ceux
avec lesquels vous avez vécu ce qui
m'est arrivé effectivement de de vivre
avec un animal qui était moulouk je
pense que vous avez connu sous le nom et
le chien au contact de l'homme devient
de plus en plus humain et l'homme au
contact du chien devient de plus en plus
animale pour en revenir au cinéma et à
votre carrière jamais vous n'avez sauter
à travers autant que sonne être franchie
autant de barrage en flammes
est-ce que ça à quoi ça correspond chez
vous vous avez besoin vous prouver vous
pouvez le faire c'est celle ci seulement
cela c'est le destin ça on n'y peut rien
parce que quand j'étais gosse
mon rêve c'était de la servante c'était
le signe de zorro s'étaient tous les
films de douglas fairbanks mai
ma carrière au début m'a orienté vers
mots plutôt m'a mis au service de la
poésie et des poètes qui était jean
cocteau qui est pour moi l'homme que
j'aime bien le plus au monde et à qui je
dois le plus et j'ai poussé jean cocteau
une fois à me faire un film de cape et
l'épée qui était pourtant pas vrai sujet
de cape et d'épée puisque c'était ruy
blas mais il en a fait avec le rôle de
safari un acteur de cape et d'épée un
personnage de cape et l'épée et j'ai cru
que ce serait fini
et puis quelques années après on m'a
demandé pour le bossu et puis il se
trouve que ce film a fait beaucoup
d'argent et les producteurs s'attachant
beaucoup à l'argent ont voulu refaire ce
genre de film et maintenant me le
demande souvent ce genre de film mais
entre temps j'ai fait des films qui
n'étaient pas de cape et l'épée comme la
princesse de clèves et comme ponce
pilate qui n'est pas encore sortie va
sortir prochainement leurs escales
surprenant c'est que nous expliquer que
vous n'avez pas obéi en faisant du sport
qu'on n'avait pas bougé et c'est à nous
tous vos films vous en fait plus que les
autres vous refuse d'être doublé et même
vous en rajoutez uniquement parce que je
considère que si on accepte ce genre de
rose
il faut faire jusqu'au bout autrement il
ya quelque chose de pas très honnête je
trouve autrement alors on n'a qu'à
choisir un accroc date doit il semble
qu'il se soit produit pour vous un peu
ce qui s'est produit pour jean gabin une
certaine époque de sa carrière c'est à
dire qu'après avoir eu beaucoup de
succès vous l'avez connu un certain
passage à vide et que vous êtes revenu
parce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est
faux aura les journaux et la télévision
la radio l'a dit alors je pense que
c'est vrai mais en réalité c'est parce
que j'ai fait du théâtre et que pendant
je faisais du théâtre pendant deux ans
on m'a faire que les films que je devais
tourner en grande partie en extérieur et
je ne pouvais pas donc les accepter
c'est uniquement ça moi je n'ai donc pas
eu cette impression parce que j'ai le
même nombre de propositions pour les
contrats ce qui est effectivement pour
vous j'ai tourné moins de films
il ya beaucoup d'acteurs qui veut ça va
m'arriver dans l'année prochaine je vais
jouer au théâtre et ce serait moi mais
je veux dire que j'ai beaucoup d'acteurs
fond du cap souvent parce qu'on leur
propose tout le film
je fume important d'aliments mais c'est
en tout cas moi ça n'a pas été mon cas
ce n'est pas mon cas non tu n'es
prochaine est ce que vous croyez qu'un
acteur peut sentir si le décile décline
dans l'esprit du public ou pas oui j'ai
pas sûr parce que ils continuent à être
harcelées de la même manière il est
encore une vedette pour le public mais
n'est plus pour les producteurs café
magna lalanne être forcément sensible et
s'il est en baisse je pense qu'il le
sang vous êtes jamais dit à aucun moment
ça marche moins bien pour moi j'ai pu le
même nombre de propositions
intéressantes je parle à la jean marc
ayrault jean marais au rabais et si les
propositions intéressantes non je parle
pas ou feint du prix et les prix n'ont
jamais baissé mais c'est à dire que
pendant des années j'ai eu la chance de
faire des films pour porto et pour
clément un poids de la noix pour des
metteurs en scène important et que
effectivement depuis quelques années je
n'ai pas les propositions de ce genre de
mettre en scène ni d'auteur et clément
par exemple vous rencontrez vous
proposer plus de films
c'est à dire que quand je rencontre
clément aux clouzeaux et ils me disent
qu'ils aimeraient beaucoup faire un film
avec moi mais qui n'ont pas de sujet
pour moi et je crois que cela vient
beaucoup de de la pénurie des sujets car
au théâtre les directeurs de théâtre se
plaignent de ça et les producteurs et
les metteurs en scène se plaignent aussi
lé sa et par exemple j'ai fait des
essais ggd plusieurs jeunes metteurs en
scène mais comme caste par exemple et ça
ne m'a pas réussi parce que j'avais
confiance en ce jeune metteur en scène
par ses paroles par tout ce qu'il me
disait et finalement il a prouvé que à
mon avis je dois dire qu'il n'était pas
quelqu'un de d'important il est très
intéressant mais peut-être qu'un autre
vous aurez apporté le oui mais ça je le
ferais j'ai fait avec vous avez su avec
cast oui mais par exemple avec voix sol
non avec trois heures que j'étais ravie
j'ai délai donné sa chance
il a fait son premier
il a ça moi et j'en suis ravi ce serait
à refaire leur faire je ne demanderai la
même chose s'il m'amène à scénario je
juge bon est valable je l'aiderai de la
même façon si ma participation peut être
capable de l'aider que quand vous êtes
déçu par quelqu'un en grec c'est un nom
c'est à dire oh non non non j'en veux ni
à la personne moi je ma ligne de
conduite c'est toujours de m'en vouloir
à moi